spielen macht in die hand wünschen sich
natürlich neue stars naja erstmal muss
man ja sagen dass wir einen exzellenten
kader haben das hat man ja auch am
dienstag in dortmund wieder gesehen und
natürlich beobachtet der hasan mit
seiner mannschaft den markt sehr genau
das ist auch seine aufgabe und das
machen sie auch gewissenhaft
und insofern wenn irgendwas am markt ist
was zum fc bayern mittel und langfristig
passt was wir glauben dass wir unbedingt
haben wollte um die mannschaft weiter zu
verstärken und was auch in einem
gewissen finanziellen rahmen ist dann
wird das ich sicherlich darum bemühen
aber wir haben jetzt keinen akuten
bedarf wie man ja gesehen hat am
dienstag die stimmung wollen sie das
spiel dort sehr beeindruckend harlan
sagt wieder weil er funktioniert und
trotzdem alle reden über land bayern ist
so was überhaupt möglich also zunächst
mal möchte ich sagen dass wir nach
meinem dafürhalten weltbesten stürmer in
unseren eigenen reihen haben den
weltfußballer robert lewandowski und wir
haben das wieder gesehen hat die letzten
zwei mal der ist eine torgarantie also
wir sind unheimlich happy mit robert der
ist noch zwei jahre bei uns und
hoffentlich vielleicht sogar noch länger
der lehrling an design hervorragender
spieler ist überhaupt keine frage und
das sieht man ja auch normalerweise an
den wochenenden wenn er verdorrten und
spielt aber wie ich schon gesagt habe
wir haben den weltbesten dann mit dem
sie mir unwahrscheinlich zufriedenen
happy robert hat einmal erzählt an test
machen lassen wie alt sein körper
wirklich ist und der körper ist
angeblich drei vier jahre jünger als die
biologische echtzeit glauben sie denn er
kann auch noch so lange spielen weil in
der woche hat man so ein bisschen auch
bei uns lesen können er wird sich ein
bisschen rocken und natürlich seinen
berater dass der fc bayern schon mit dem
vertragsangebot zur verlängerung auf ihn
zukommt weil sie ein karriereschritt ist
es ja vielleicht der letzte da noch ein
bisschen planen würde naja zum einen wie
schon gesagt habe sind wir
wahrscheinlich zufrieden und hätte mit
robert aber wir müssen jetzt auch nicht
heute den vertrag verlängern nach meinem
dafürhalten wir hatten auch wie gesagt
zwei jahre wir sind in permanenten
austausch mit unseren spielern und auch
einem robert lewandowski und ich hab das
ja auch schon mal gesagt ich könnte mir
gut vorstellen dass er den vertrag auch
mit ihm verlängern aber das ist noch zu
früh jetzt fangen wir erstmal die
bundesliga-saison anziehen wie es da
läuft